Avengers endgame was heavy on the
fanservice cameos but one brief
appearance was meant for a specific type
of fan during one key scene in the
multi-billion dollar blockbuster
sharp-eyed viewers spotted Matthew Barry
the ESPN fantasy sports experts as a
SHIELD agent an appearance made possible
by co-director Joe Russo's fantasy
football obsession Barry was easy to
miss due to the fact that his turn was
slightly overshadowed by another much
more high profile cameo it came during
the scene in which Tony Stark Steve
Rogers and Scott Lang having just
snagged the tesseract during the return
trip to 2012's Battle of New York are
confronted by a phallic sub-agents
insisting that they turn it over to
shield custody they are led by Alexander
Pierce whom the pair know thanks to the
events of Captain America the Winter
Soldier to be a Hydra turncoat mayhem
ensues and Loki ends up escaping with
the tesseract but not before Barry was
given his brief time to shine as one of
the agents flanking Pierce it's not
often that a fantasy sports guru even an
extremely successful and knowledgeable
one finds himself sharing the frame with
the biggest stars in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe and one stone-cold
screen icon in one of the biggest movies
of all time but according to Barry it
all came about due to Russo's
familiarity with his work owing to the
directors rabbit fantasy fandom speaking
in an interview with IO 9 he said it
happened through the grace of Joe Russo
he's been reading my column for years
and he's a big fantasy football player
about two years ago he gave me a call
and said hey man I got a part that I
think is perfect for you if you want to
be in the movie and I was like yeah of
course obviously Barry went on to
explain that he was told he'd be playing
somebody quotes official and that he'd
be sharing the screen with for the Hulk
and Iron Man his head was still
presumably spinning in disbelief when he
got a call from someone in endgames
costume department to get his suit size
which led him to believe that his part
would be that of a police detective or
the like since of course shield had long
since disbanded and the flicks
time-travel elements weren't yet public
knowledge somebody peed my pants
Travel when he arrived on set in
November 2017 Barry signed a phone books
worth of NBA's before getting his hands
on his script pages which simply
confused the heck out of it according to
Barry they hand me the script it's like
two pages and it makes no sense to me
all it is is the dialogue
I see dialog between Alexander Pierce my
character Tony Stark and Thor then you
see like one or two lines from other
Tony and I'm saying what the heck is
other Tony you had asked once the actual
business of shooting the scene commenced
Barry cop to being just as starstruck as
the rest of us would have been in his
situation saying forget actors forget
movie stars
I'm surrounded by iconic legends I mean
I'm in a frame with Robert Downey jr.
Robert Redford Chris Hemsworth and me
like one of the shots in the movie is
literally just the four of us that's
bananas to think about of course as soon
as it dawned on him what the scene
setting was and who he was sharing it
with Barry became keenly aware of just
why he'd had to sign all those NDA's
this guy's seen how we put the pieces
together Barry recalled I'm in the lobby
of stark tower they're all wearing what
they were wearing in the Avengers
clearly it's either a flashback or it's
time-travel also Alexander Pierce is
there he's dead of course for roughly a
year and a half until endgames released
he couldn't share a single detail of the
scene that he'd shot including the fact
that he'd literally been in frame with
Robert freakin Redford with anybody not
even his wife as if hobnobbing with one
of the greatest actors of all time
weren't cool enough Barry went on to
relate that Tony Stark himself had gone
out of his way to encourage him during
the shoot saying Downey turned to me and
said you're doing very well he said
don't take this the wrong way but you
look like a SHIELD agent and I said
Robert coming from you that's an amazing
compliment I will take that thank you
very much
kid
an Avenger named Barry wrapped up the
interview by noting that he felt he'd
nailed his role by virtue of well not
standing out at all as he put it the
scene is about Tony Stark and Thor
running into Alexander Pierce while they
have Loki and the tesseract that's what
the scene is about you don't want anyone
to take you out of that moment the fact
that they just go oh look there's a
shield guy there makes me feel like I
did a good job we concur and we'll be
anxiously awaiting the announcement of
the standalone flick what's his name
agent of shield or maybe Hydra for
Marvel space for his greatest strength
fantasy picks you can count on at least
then tell the entire organization up and
betrays you check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about the MCU were coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]